there's some things money can't buy we
don't like the idea of treating parts of
the body as commodities as beautiful a
sentiment as altruism is it just isn't
enough
[Music]
people have two kidneys situated on the
back behind the ribcage they look more
or less like a bean
and kidneys are organs that filter waste
material from the blood
and process that into urine they're
extremely important because if your
kidneys are failing you're collecting
quite a bit of waste material which is
detrimental for all other organ systems
[Music]
a typical dialysis patient has a poorer
life expectancy than many cancers
after decades of experimenting in 1954
it was the first successful human
transplant which revolutionized the
field
my daughter was involved in a car
accident it was clear that her injuries
weren't survivable
but fee had let us know that if anything
had happened
she would want to
give her organs
so when we arrived at the hospital and
were given that devastating news
you know this felt like something that
we could all get behind and for
something positive to come out of such a
sad time i mean what an incredible
legacy
we
saved for people's lives on that day
[Music]
in 2006 i went for a regular checkup and
i felt fine but the blood work that i
got showed that my kidneys were in very
very bad shape i had to either go on
dialysis hooked up to a machine
for three to four hours a day about
three times a week or i would have to
try to find a donor
lots of people still don't know that
many people could actually donate a
kidney removing one kidney should not
affect someone's lifespan and also
should not affect someone's life quality
a kidney from a living donor in general
will have a much better quality because
it comes from a healthy and tested
person kidneys are expected to survive
up to twice as long on average in a
recipient
i was lucky i had two people who were
willing to sacrifice a body part to me
leaves you speechless with gratitude but
it also leaves you speechless with
sorrow and anger that there are so many
people who don't have friends or
relatives who can give them a kidney
and who die waiting for one to become
available so that's how i became very
interested in our organ transplant
system and how we should change it
no one needs two kidneys and there are
many desperate people who need one if
they were compensated their lives could
be improved at little cost to their
health while saving the life of someone
else
the idea is to offer people
a in-kind benefit not cash but maybe
loan forgiveness or a tuition voucher or
a contribution to their retirement
account
in exchange for a kidney
if i were a patient with failing kidneys
and i faced a short and miserable life
and i had the opportunity to buy a
kidney and was assured that the donor
was being properly compensated
you bet i'd take that option
currently it's not allowed to donate a
kidney under any form of payment we rely
on the good will of people to help
others
it's not the wealthy who would be
wanting to sell their organs it's people
who are on the poverty line in very
desperate situations and those people
are also the most vulnerable people in
terms of poor health in later life
[Music]
incentivizing people to donate more
is actually a way to starve black
markets it's not to recreate them it's
to undermine them if you reward a person
amply for the sacrifice they've made
something they go into with their eyes
open and well informed that's not
expectation
[Music]
no one really knows what will happen if
you start doing this because even though
personally i'm not necessarily fully
against it if it would drive people to
donate but the effect could be that it
all becomes a business transaction and
that the more obvious donors may not
donate because they will tell the
recipient or you can go and buy a kidney
right it might actually reduce the
number of people that want to donate
because they don't want to be involved
in such a scheme all of a sudden
transplantation becomes
a thing that you can organize as long as
you can pay for it
people are dreaming to build kidneys in
the laboratory buy bioprinted or 3d
printed organ structures modified pig
organs so that's a revolution
[Music]
this is the only way to solve the
problem it's so much needless death
it feels like an incredible gift and i
don't know how that gift can be
quantified
when we're considering this policy
option most of us don't kind of weigh
the pros and cons but often we're
offended at the very idea selling
kidneys is so immoral i can only liken
it to the woman who goes out on the
street and sells sex it's an example of
a secular taboo in my view the full
potential of living donation has not yet
been achieved without using money
why are we not maximizing deceased
donation we don't talk about our wishes
research shows that most people would
agree after death to organ donation
yet we leave our loved ones wondering
ideally
we could change the law but i would
advocate that anyone consider donating
no matter what because save dragging
someone out of a burning building or
pulling them out of a frozen lake where
else could you save someone's life so
palpably
as this
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video